[Music]
what's up guys today I'm going to show
you how a low-level Pandu barrows very
easily my stats are very low 53 tech 55
strength 46 defense 62 range 43 prayer
and only 51 magic my combat is only 66
on do burrows very easily so this is my
setup 5 prayer panting I'm only used to
but it's better to be safe than sorry a
bunch of lobsters because barrack hits
through prayer and I was accumulator for
when you need the kill count I'm a
teleport to Morton some death rating
some thyroids and then here's my setup
it's a very low cost
the fish here home the inlet of glory
ancient cloak for some prayer saradomin
robe top which actually is the same as a
monk robe basically I don't know why
about that when I bolts I've been staff
you were in plate legs from boots comma
bracelet and ring wealth
alright so to start your trip you just
teleport tomorrow
and you actually don't need to bring a
spade because there's one on the way
so one east
across this bridge
so about right here this is when I
normally turn off my run energy and
gets paid from this area you can see
where
it's not working right
take your stay down here
so the order I do is Carol's and then
arum and then Derek and Derek and then
toerag and then Guffin so Carol is at
the very south unless the first one you
wanna start with and
you'd think you'd want to use range but
actually mage kills Carol very easily so
dig right here
get your prayers ready well turn on
protect from range and
it makes hit through them very
easily
the I'm only 51 and I'm destroying bombs
or high heads Wow I
use any prayer
turn off your mage turn on your on here
and let's get going it's very important
to watch your perk and anytime one of
their heads pops up your prayer gets
drained a little bit
now we're doing mmm so I'll switch to
your okay
so you thought it kind of hidden tunnel
so that's we're going to saving for last
because that means you can take us to
though basically the maze
Duke here now this is Derek in the top
right and
he can it very high so make sure you
maintain your prayer
see that Facebook tips on my previous
training a little bit so kind of watch
it at 19 okay
little barracks over knock over
equitable equality it's through prayer
very easily so you don't need to use
prayer now this is we're going to use
your lobsters because he will hit you
pretty easily once a while much fun in
some axes but he has hit a twenty
following me before
he is playing a hit
you
could have been killed
okay right on
we'll go to toerag
target area week but still use prior to
sometimes
okay so this is very cheap gear very
easy
already done like six chests that I
this gear
and then the six chess I just got 100
Garga thinset subversion
so one over to Gotham
you
almost
now we go to the tunnel I think Aaron is
the one that was not there
now this is where you go down to the
maze
so click it
yes all right fearless
okay so I want to find the open doors I
guess I'll just go to sign in go this
way
and mmm will spawn
Michigan person
so range fire
so basically if you open these doors mm
or the final brother that you did not
kill will randomly appear if you could
just open a door over an overnight from
the parent but I know if I just run
around
make sure your purse this arm can hit
pretty high and you can even train your
stuff a little bit
oh
okay colonel
let's make a settlement to prayer pods
very sorry kill the brothers in yho
counting it up so you need to go
about in to kill 14
14 years I'm under way to click the
lower levels is a little too high for my
right thing
ok I'll kill this
so my person is trained
so you need to kill
14 total so I believe that 6 plus 8
creatures
wow this is really pointed out is
killing it
you need to kill the six bonus plus 8
more creatures I
use always buddy so it kind of tells me
so right now I'm at 70% so when I get
200 only when I stop that you can keep
calendar pictures of you on
chest is in there those little thing
I'm going to count the level 50 twos for
rats
and rats position higher levels about
96 percent
we're trying to get some lower levels
going on
their station house
so the idea is the higher
well when you get 14 to account your
potential is out of hundred percent so
you have a better chance of a farmer and
more rooms I
can set I've done six chests and I just
got raised so I have that some ammo
this guy's just having this finally
don't type again
you get away just so I can get a
different monster
right back into ERISA one over here
we type a little number one
so if you have high attack and strength
you can see the lip in but I don't have
enough
you
only it is anything officers but this is
where I
see
alright so one my monster a little bit
understand
you
Oh
this is really important I hear
all right so I'm here and now each time
the door is going to have a pattern
square so I would just look like there's
three patterns and the pretties that
final lines type in burrows bag all
right so let's see what we get
all right salute all right guys thanks
for watching I hope that helps you low
level to pit level do burrows easier and
I'm currently on 21 chests and I'm going
to continue and do about 100 and then
upload a video of all the armor I get if
any all right so stay tuned for next
video thanks guys